el parlamento israelí knéset fue
disuelto llevando a las quintas
elecciones en menos de cuatro años y el
nombre del primer ministro naftalí
bennett no estará en la carrera
electoral
quiero hacerles saber que no tengo
intención de presentarme a las próximas
elecciones pero seguiré siendo un leal
servidor de este país al que he servido
toda mi vida como soldado oficial
ministro y como primer ministro
tras varias dimisiones benet anunció el
colapso de su coalición de ocho partidos
en la semana pasada tras sólo un año de
mandato pero aseguró estar orgulloso de
sus logros hoja semana gracias adiós
dejó atrás un país próspero fuerte y
seguro el gobierno bajo mi dirección ha
conseguido hacer en un año lo que muchos
gobiernos no han logrado en un mandato
completo cadencias lema benet ha cedido
el poder a su ministro de asuntos
exteriores
yair lapid que dirigirá un gobierno
provisional por lo que los dos
intercambiaron sus sillas en la knesset
se espera que la pita haga campaña para
mantenerse en el cargo de primer
ministro como su principal rival los
comicios del 1 de noviembre se espera
que se postule el primer ministro que
estuvo más tiempo en el cargo benjamin
netanyahu a pesar de los entramados de
corrupción en su contra
netanyahu afirma que su alianza con la
derecha los ultranacionalistas y los
partidos ultraortodoxos ganará las
elecciones aunque las encuestas señalan
que él también podría tener problemas
para conseguir una mayoría parlamentaria